from the spike of the Second World War
there's been a historically unusual
period of peace among developed
countries we take it for granted now
that wars are things that happen in poor
nasty parts of the world but it wasn't
always like that it was always used to
be the rich countries that fought each
other hi I'm Ron Daly for recent TV and
I'm joined today by cognitive
neuroscientist Steven Pinker from
Harvard University talking about his new
book the better angels of our nature why
violence has declined welcome thank you
very much thank you first why has
violent decline I think most people will
be astonished to hear that yes first of
all I have to convince people that
there's a fact that needs to be
explained namely that violence has
declined and it has I demonstrate with a
hundred graphs and data sets before
turning to the reasons which I think are
multiple one of them is the spread of
government the outsourcing of revenge to
a more or less disinterested third party
that tends to ramp down your rates of
vendetta and blood feud for all the
reasons that we're familiar with from
The Sopranos and The Godfather
anyway if it's always you who's the
judge jury and executioner you're always
going to think you're right you're
always gonna think the other guy is a
nefarious treacherous scoundrel who
deserves only punishment when you have
two sides both thinking that then you
can have cycles of violence if you've
got a disinterested third party there's
more likely to nip the psycho in the bud
the second one is the growth of Commerce
opportunities for positive some exchange
as opposed to zero-sum plunder when it's
cheaper to buy something than to steal
it
that changes the incentives and you get
each side valuing the other more alive
than dead it's the theory of gentle
Commerce from from the Enlightenment so
how much has violence gone down how
would you characterize it briefly do to
people from their transition from tribal
societies to settled States there was a
reduction from about a 15% chance of
dying violently down to about a 3%
chance in the first States now women
leaders within what period you have in
mind there began about five thousand
years ago in some parts of the world and
it's proceeded on evenly throughout the
rest of the world so why is it though
that people tend to tend to believe that
violence is increasing why why do we
have that perception i I have been at a
conference for example where I outlined
your thesis briefly to a panel of fairly
distinguished political scientists and
economists and they rejected it out of
hand they said but the 20th century Ron
the twenty century was horrible millions
died yeah well millions died in
centuries before the 20th so people
confuse a data point with a trend they
remember the horrific episodes of
violence in the 20th century but but but
one occurrence is not a trend and
despite universal predictions that world
war 1 into World War two just the
beginning of a sequence where World War
three be even worse
World War three didn't happen and in
fact from the spike of the Second World
War there's been a historically unusual
period of peace among developed
countries we take it for granted now
that wars are things that happen in poor
nasty parts of the world but it wasn't
always like that it was always used to
be the rich countries that fought each
other and the great powers state the
800-pound gorillas at any given period
in history or constantly in each other's
face since the since the end of the
Korean War that hasn't been a great
power war it's not an enormous stretch
of history but it's not an insignificant
slice either now you said that there was
the longest period of peace in five
hundred years uh really that's right
that's certainly the longest period of
great power peace probably since the
Roman Empire also with the news media
follow the policy if it bleeds it leads
if millions of people die of Alzheimer's
and heart attacks and cancer
there isn't a news crew filming those
deaths but if a dozen people get blown
blown to bits by a terrorist bomb you
can be sure we'll be reading about it
and so given that the human mind
estimates risk by how easily can recall
examples that's a basic discovery of
cognitive psychology and there are
always enough incidents of violence and
absolutely terms to fill the news
our perception of violence is going to
be disconnected from the proportions
some people are gonna go oh you know
Steven Pinker is over interpreting this
random period this fluctuation just
happened to be a peaceful period and
something terrible is going to happen
how could you say that perhaps you
aren't over interpreting yeah I don't
think something terrible could happen
there's a there is a big dose of
randomness in human history and some
coming fanatic somewhere might be
promoting a new movement that will gain
adherents and lead to boodles
insurgencies and repression maybe some
hot egg will get control of China and
decide well it's finally time to rectify
the historic injustice of Taiwan once
and for all and who knows what would
happen if they decided to act on it
stuff happens what doesn't happen though
is what is a cycles build up and release
meanly well every year that has passed
without a war means we're more and more
due for the next one like tensions have
been building up it's only a matter of
time before they'll burst that doesn't
happen and and that's the mental model
that a lot of people have some kind of
cycles or periodicity in history and I
think there's no evidence for that
though there is evidence for the
occasional very unpleasant surprise why
did this arise now why are we
experiencing yeah why is it the last 50
or 60 years I I suspect that it is again
the spread of information that I may not
be a coincidence that it's the McLuhan
start of the cliche that we live in a
global global village thanks to
electronic media we sense other people's
ways of life much more immediately they
feel much more like part of the family
even if we are not like them but also
the revival of the Enlightenment
acceleration of argument debate
knowledge rational examination of how we
live our lives I guess reason to put in
a little plug for our sponsor
because it's amazing how quickly a lot
of these customs crumbled once they were
just put under the microscope you really
come down to it should homosexuality you
know be illegal you're gonna lose that
argument you could you can grasp at
straws well the Bible says so well our
ancestors did it that way but they
aren't very good arguments reminds me of
something that Tim Ferriss said that
there is the scientific method and that
liberalism is also a method it is not an
ideology it is a way of approaching the
world and trying to find out what works
absolutely and that was that's one of
the toxic features of the deadly
ideologies of the 20th century perhaps
the best example is Mao's Great Leap
Forward where it was a screwball idea
for all kinds of reasons but one of them
was as people were dying by the millions
he didn't change his mind
it was stay the course full speed ahead
I don't care about reality I've had this
this this brainchild and I'm gonna
impose it on this country come what may
it's a sobering lesson for all forms of
political belief systems including
libertarianism that is you've got to be
receptive to signals from the world
telling you whether your ideas really
are making people better off or not do
you think this beneficial trend this
trend toward less violence is likely to
continue for the 21st century I think
some forms are likely to continue I
think the campaign to target certain
categories and violence and to bring
shaming campaigns against them worldwide
are likely to succeed as they succeeded
in the past four forms of
institutionalized violence like slavery
and piracy you and whaling so for
example I think violence against women
is likely to go down because there's
pressure both from the bottom up and the
top down I think that probably capital
punishment will continue to decline
that's certainly been the the trend I
think the beating of children will
completely decline cases where there's a
society-wide practice and social norms
determined that the current level there
are other kinds of violence that are
much more sporadic chaotic unpredictable
they're it's much harder to predict so
for example civil wars and where you
don't have a responsible pair of
governments making the conscious
decision to go to war something it's
kind of falling out of fashion but you
can always get some nasty little militia
or insurgency doing a bunch of damage
crime rates have defied every expert
prediction and I think would be foolish
to say they couldn't go up again given
that they go up when people expect them
to go down and vice versa thank you very
much Steve for coming in and talking to
us about your fabulous new book the
better angels of our nature why violence
has declined for reason TV I'm Ron
Bailey